you know the number one question at this  conference is will d5 disrupt the  existing financial markets and the  answer is  100  yes when you buy a stock in switzerland  or germany or in england you either pay  in swiss francs euros or british pounds  and i do that all the time but before i  can do that i have to take us dollars  and exchange it into the local currency  let's say euros every time i do that i  have to pay a currency trader  now that is zero value added to me when  we get d5 working in regulators on both  sides of the pawn degree i can do that  transaction with zero cost or next to  zero so that will make it more efficient  that's just one use and by the way the  currency market is a multi-trillion  dollar market the largest in the world  full of friction full of cost full of  fees you have to pay d5 will eliminate  that i'm very excited about that that's  just one application there's so many  more